jamais mais c'est là bas puis le docteur
radio a lancé peut être n'est pas sûr
d'être à ce soir quand chaque minute
compte et que le réseau de la santé
refuse qu'on transporte un patient en
hélicoptère c'est un peu le far west
actuellement pour ce qui est de
l'encadrement des transports alternatifs
c'est une tragédie à cause d'un manque
de coordination si vous êtes dans le
fond des bois et que vous devez vite
aller à l'hôpital vous serez sûrement
soulagé de penser que vous pouvez être
évacués à toute vitesse par hélicoptère
mais dans la réalité c'est pas si simple
est ce qu'on a découvert c'est qu'un
mauvais arrimage entre le service de
transport par hélicoptère et le réseau
de la santé
ça peut créer des situations qui tourne
mal
[Musique]
catena campagne très mal à perdre en
qualité
le téléphone rampeau c'est un paysage
que tout le monde vienne puis peuvent
pas oublier que du mal à c'est mon rêve
que vous menez passe mais vous y êtes à
ces moments avec les fils l'endroit de
rêve de lawrence tremblay c'est son
chalet au nord du lac saint jean il en a
construit une partie de ses propres
mains et il vient le plus souvent
possible avec sa famille était comme
hiver à 16 heures de folie
s'il espère passer séjour ici il
n'aurait jamais imaginé qu'il passerait
prédit mourir et c'est pourtant ce qui
est arrivé l'année dernière où lendemain
du jour de l'an mais quand fredonner
ville que le toit de mon chalet
je suis après dix minutes que l'on a
recommencé plus senti des malades
en fait il est quelques smartphones puis
je vais aussi me taire bon match nul 2-2
mais d'atteinte à 140 trouve le port
baissé
monsieur tremblay a perdu plusieurs
membres de sa famille à cause de
problèmes cardiaques
mais cette famille pour sa 16 à 4
suivent à l'insu de cardiologie par
chabbert à la voie des problèmes jours
il avait tout prévu pour être évacués
rapidement par hélicoptère en cas
d'urgence
mais ça n'a pas fonctionné je pense
qu'on peut dire c'est un peu le far west
actuellement pour ce qui est de
l'encadrement des transports alternatifs
monsieur tremblay a été victime d'une
faille dans notre système il en paie
maintenant le pli avec sa santé
à partir de maintenant chaque minute
compte pour lawrence tremblay il doit
rapidement quitté le chalet qui n'a pas
de réseau cellulaire et qui est
difficile d'accès pour les secours c'est
chaud car après deux cas personne à mon
chalet pour se ranger pour appelé
l'hélicoptère par l'hélicoptère pour me
transporter il faut qu'une dizaine de
minutes assez proches sur une route
secondaire pour le transporter à base de
plein air
d'où on appellera discours thunder
caravane cher d'après midi par prudence
il est abonné depuis dix ans un service
d'évacuation médicale par hélicoptère ou
coup d'une centaine de dollars par année
l'at-elle à air médic est logé à 13h
c'est en principe le scénario sera le
suivant l'hélicoptère partira de la base
de saguenay prendra le patient à la base
de plein air et le transportera à
chicoutimi qui possèdent l'équipement
spécialisé pour le cas et ce fut le cas
chez les scouts mine lapa s'en sortir de
là parce que j'ai dans mazda parenté qui
sont cardiaque pcc chicoutimi ces parts
valent ni dolbeau c'est chicoutimi pour
pour les problèmes cardiaques
mais entre-temps croyant bien faire ont
été moins à la base de plein air at elle
aussi le 9 1 1
c'est là que les choses se compliquent
l'appel passe par le centre de
communication santé
le ccs des capitales à 13h15 une minute
plus tard le répartiteur affecte une
ambulance du village voisin de normande
13h18 air médic apprend que l'ambulance
est en route
l'hélicoptère n'a pas encore décollé
airmédic appelle le ccs pour évaluer la
pertinence de déployer quand même son
équipage dans la transcription des
échanges on voit la confusion qui
s'installe les rôles de chacun ne sont
pas claires pas nécessaire de déployer
répond le ccs puisque les ambulanciers
arriveront sous peu au moins deux fois
airmédic demande si l'hôpital le plus
proche celui de dolbeau est équipé d'un
centre des mots d'une amie pour traiter
les problèmes cardiaques
le répondant du ccs semblé hésiter et
suggère coup pire ils pourront
retransférer le patient plus tard
je comprends pas c'est moi qui paye air
médic css de capital qui nous
interdisent la chercher c'est aberrant
comme situation
jean françois leroux est avocat
spécialisé dans les affaires médicales
si tu as peut-être de plus chacun dans
cette histoire là c'est qu'on a des
intervenants qui semble être conscient
que les services que requiert monsieur
c'est une angioplastie donc avec un
service d'hémodynamie on semble avoir
connu une situation qui était
potentiellement très grave mais on n'y a
pas donné suite adéquatement l'appel der
medic et transférés aux superviseurs de
la centrale qui répond il est peut être
membre chez vous mais c'est notre
patient après coup voici comment un
vice-président d'hermétique expliqué
monsieur tremblay ce qui s'est passé
c'est certainement pas un débat entre
les services privés les services publics
s'est passé du tout la situation en fait
c'est tout simplement que ces deux
entités la se sont battus pour savoir
qui allait s'occuper de monsieur pendant
que monsieur se battait pour sauver sa
vie
13h44 airmédic annuler la mission
sauvetage sans demander l'avis de
monsieur tremblay il est pourtant
conscient et aptes à prendre la décision
j'ai reçu hier me dis que je n'ai pas
encore fait de commentaires la roi des
problèmes parce que le sexe avec un trou
monsieur tremblay a raison de
s'inquiéter
son coeur est en danger explique la
docteure annick du charme de l'institut
de cardiologie de montréal parce que
c'est un l'obstruction d'une artère de
lapin importe leur sein et qui contient
de l'oxygène et une autre immense si le
coeur la messe n'est pas nourri mais
vous mourrez et la première est critique
nous on a aussi notre golden hour si
vous vouliez et idéalement rétablir la
circulation au bout du quart dans l'art
qui suit l'événement
[Musique]
14h41 une heure et demie s'est déjà
écoulée lorsque monsieur tremblay arrive
au triage de l'hôpital le plus proche
celui de dolbeau quel est le groupe le
fait vraiment paniqués ils ont composé
des moines et j'ai compris que s'ils me
calmait pas allez pouvoir travers vous
c'est prenait trop tahiti sur les sapins
cemac à n'importe quoi pour ce travail
puis leur ai dit que si je marque c'est
fini le jeu tu es prêt à partir une fois
sur place on stabilise son état comme il
craignait on lui annonce qu on doit le
transférer à chicoutimi à 125 kilomètres
de là et aucune ambulance n'est
disponible lui aurait dit l'infirmière
de garde et la réponse appel air médic
je suis couvert par un musique mon nez
me chercher si à l'hôpital avec l'eau
m'a fait la réponse airmédic offert de
transférer le patient entre les deux
hôpitaux pour gagner du temps
encore une fois le centre de
communication santé des capitales refuse
la situation nécessité un transport
aéroportée et il n'y a pas reçus service
pour lequel le pays
une des raisons pour laquelle ils ont
reçu ce service là c'est à l'évidence un
manque de coordination entre les
différents services d'intervention
préhospitalier est ce assez nettement
troublant parce qu'on semble pas avoir
eu le meilleur intérêt de monsieur en
tête lorsque ces décisions ont été
prises
des heures cruciales s'écoule vers 17h15
il arrive à chicoutimi par ambulance
terrestre un montant jamais médecins à
bord l'infirmière les deux ambulanciers
puis le docteur radio à leblanc s'est
préparé les pour le défibrillateur passe
à dire
[Musique]
être les passions de salon
lorsqu'ils entrent enfin en salle
d'hémodynamie plus de cinq heures et
demi se sont écoulés depuis son malaise
et est malheureusement ces problèmes ne
font que commencer
[Musique]
le québec en retard sur les autres
provinces
on poursuit notre enquête tout c'est
après cette pause
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un cliché lawrence tremblay m
cueillir des bleuets depuis qu'il a
frôlé la mort il profite de chaque
instant
mais son quotidien est plus compliqué
qu'avant mais il a moins d'énergie que
breivik
depuis son impact us selon une
évaluation médicale
son coeur aurait perdu une grande partie
de ses capacités
ça te fais dans ma ville avec l'excédent
que j'ai eus fait que oui sûrement
passer le restant demi-gros aussi frais
pu en france comme j'étais avant pour
toi toi aller prendre une marche aux 1 2
finales par soirée
un staff pas pu le faire monsieur
tremblay a le sentiment qu'on l'a laissé
tomber le jour de son accident il a
cherché à comprendre ce qui s'est passé
il a appelé airmédic je parle à herm et
serq les en aurais dû travailler
ensemble mais ils n'ont pas fait mais
ses multiples produits
hier midi qui lui a dit déplorer le
manque de collaboration de certaines
centrales d'ambulances des lacunes dans
le système au niveau des centrales de
répartition des ambulances les ccs ont
été mis au jour en 2014
dans un rapport du comité national sur
les services préhospitaliers on y
apprend qu'ils ne sont pas soumis à des
normes de certification obligatoire
qu'il peut y avoir apparence de conflit
d'intérêts avec des entreprises
ambulancières et que leur reddition de
comptes et nettement déficiente
à partir du moment où ce que ya pas de
reddition de compte il n'y a pas de
contrôle de qualité ainsi a pas de
contrôle de qualité ça devient un peu
encore une fois le far west qui on
assiste au manque de coordination qu'on
compte qu'on constate une hausse de 6
pourtant air médic existe depuis
longtemps
d'abord créé comme organisme à but non
lucratif le service a été privatisée en
2012 d investissement de 50 millions lui
ont permis de construire trois bases et
d'acquérir ses propres appareils mais en
presque vingt ans airmédic n'a jamais
été formellement reconnu par le
gouvernement
et c'est un problème on travaille
justement ce qu'il en est des
réglementations qu'à établir les
standards de qualité pour faire en sorte
que la population du québec ayant un
service kické qui est fiable piqué de
qualité donc certain que nous on prône
pour une réglementation le transport
médical héliporté a pourtant fait ses
preuves
en europe le blessé est hélitreuillé en
urgence direction l'hôpital est partout
en amérique du nord
on l'a vu lors du terrible accident qui
a décimé l'équipe de hockey junior
majeur de hambourg
au printemps le drame qui a fait 14
morts et 15 blessés
ce coup vraiment tout le pays plusieurs
victimes ont été sauvés grâce à la
rapidité d'intervention des secours
coordonnés à un services héliportés
parlez-en à des voeux de mort de sa
photo sur le mur de l'hôpital général de
montréal est aussi grande que sa
réputation chirurgien et pionnier en
traumatologie
il milite depuis des années en faveur de
services héliportés
je lui écris une lettre très dur lui
disant que j'étais gêné d'être québécois
cobac
il dit avoir personnellement interpellé
l'ex-ministre barrette
j'étais gêné parce que si un accident de
ce genre devait survenir ici j'aurais
peur qu'il y ait des morts inutiles d'un
soldat
pendant un bref moment le rêve du
docteur maure 2 a failli se réaliser en
juin dernier l'ex ministre de la santé
guettant barrette a annoncé un projet
pilote avec airmédic nous annonçons un
projet pilote qui va mettre en place la
possibilité d'avoir un transport
héliporté entre six hôpitaux du québec
pendant 18 mois
les hélicoptères d'hermies dick
transporterait des patients en région
nécessitant des soins urgents et
spécialisés vers montréal pour air médic
s'était enfin l'occasion d'intégrer le
réseau de la santé
le projet pilote va nous permettre de
commencer à avoir des échanges avec le
gouvernement par rapport à commencé à
être un peu plus impliqué dans le dans
l'écosystème j'espérais québécois de
transport médical mais le projet pilote
est suspendu il n'a pas franchi l'étape
du conseil des ministres avant le
déclenchement des élections
la nouvelle ministre veut d'abord
prendre connaissance du dossier
elle décidera de son sort en temps et
lieu
en attendant le gouvernement tolère un
service d'ambulance parallèle sans
prévoir de mécanismes pour s'assurer
qu'il puisse fonctionner efficacement
avec le réseau de la santé
d'autres incidents dramatiques risque de
survenir ce trajet c'est une tragédie
qu'on ne peut pas avoir accès des soins
à cause d'un manque de coordination la
cave collège
lawrence tremblay a entamé une poursuite
en dommages contre air médic avec
confiance en raison de tout le monde il
fonda publicité partout que sont
requises mali my happy qui répondent à
n'importe clip espérance qui viennent me
chercher
ils l'ont pas fait je trouve ça dommage
parce que des dommages la poursuite vise
aussi le centre de communication santé
des capitales ni le ccs ni air médic
n'ont souhaité commenter son cas précis
monsieur tremblay dit seulement espérer
que son cas amène des changements c'est
vraiment ma vie qui est un jeu long
j'aurais pu n'importe quelle terre que
crever un montant de lbo montages course
mais c'est certainement une lucarne sur
un problème et pour lesquelles j'ai
aucune raison de croire qui est isolé à
l'évidence il ya eu un manque de
leadership dans les dernières années
pour ce qui est de l'encadrement de ces
services là d'autant plus que depuis
on a déjà dressé le problème on a nommé
le problème alors maintenant faudrait y
répondre pu mettre en place des
structures adéquates
la santé de lawrence tremblay n'a pas
cessé de se détériorer depuis son
accident
on a dû lui implanter un défibrillateur
cardiaque
il doit supporter de nombreuses
complications médicales qui exige un
suivi régulier
les avis qu'on a obtenus nous permettre
de croquer monsieur aurait pu l'éviter
en fait d'avoir un indice ou pro nadal
qui est associée à une prise de
médication importante dont il est
évident que ce délai la 3e rue des des
conséquences très importantes sur sa
santé puis pour la santé joue également
[Musique]
le plus difficile pour ce grand
bricoleur c'est d'avoir dû renoncer à
ces outils de vivre désormais diminuer
avec des séquelles permanentes
même le quartier d'alger vous d'un mois
et demi masqué il était très très très
chanceux de temps pour la petite
histoire
monsieur tremblay à renouveler son
abonnement à air médic il l'a fait même
si le service n'est toujours pas
réglementée conscient que si son coeur
lâche à nouveau ça reste son seul espoir
d'être sauvés à temps
elle ne vient le danger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on espère que vous avez apprécié de
reportages de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là et revenez
nous la semaine prochaine pour une autre
enquête
[Musique]